wir wissen nicht ganz genau ob die
mutationen wirklich so ansteckend dass
wir das vermuten es könnte theoretisch
auch noch immer dahinter stecken das ist
ein super training rennt in diesem raum
niemals aber ich glaube dass ich auf der
grundlage der gespräche die ich heute
aufgefüllt haben mit anderen aus
experten und dem was wir bisher gesehen
haben was veröffentlicht ist das ist
eine variante ist die anstecker da ist
und somit also ist das so eine reale
gefahr ob diese variante in deutschland
ist ja und dann da das wissen wir nicht
wirklich genau das ist auch denkbar dass
sie sich in deutschland schon verbreitet
hat wir haben also das bisher noch nicht
ausreichend überprüfen können wir hoffen
dass das nicht der fall ist werden die
variante in deutschland noch nicht
angekommen ist dann müssen wir eben
kämpfen dafür dass es wirklich sagen es
so bleibt
und da sind natürlich die
sicherheitsbestimmungen diaz ergriffen
werden die sind unbedingt notwendig das
hat sich auch heute morgen war ebenfalls
schon gefordert dass für die flughäfen
dicht machen denn wir können derzeit
diese kombination nicht ausschließen
dass es videos deutlich ansteckender ist
und somit auch gefährlicher anhören
erwähnt hat das können wir nicht
ausschließen das ist sogar
wahrscheinlich dass es so ist und das
ist in deutschland möglicherweise noch
nicht ist und wenn dem so wäre dann ist
natürlich die abschottung über die
flughäfen eine dringend notwendige
maßnahme die jetzt auch ergriffen wurde
er zunächst hat sich richtig reagiert
weil es klar ist dass man
infektionsträger aus dass wir nicht
unbedingt nach deutschland holt wurzel
aber ich gehe davon aus dass das virus
sich bereits auf dem kontinent befindet
wir haben meldungen aus italien wir
wissen von einer dänischen infektionen
bei offenen grenzen die wir in
kontinental europa haben es ist eine
frage der zeit bis auch in deutschland
irgendwie ganz konkret wahrscheinlich
ist es dass das virus nach deutschland
kommt was du sagst ist insgesamt noch
deutschland und diese wahrscheinlichkeit
ist extrem hoch
ich liebe das würde ich mit 100 prozent
bezahlen das ist keine frage das wird
nach deutschland kommen aber die frage
ist ja wie schnell kontern
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren